would you would you uh make your dick
more sensitive to be less sensitive as a
person
[Music]
what the hell is this crabs
hold on a minute that's [__] War of
the Worlds that's a real photo of a real
thing on a real beach 100 what really
some robots they're testing are they
crabs look at this let me show you
another picture is it like a old Shell
that's left behind and then the they
climbed out and [__] nah because it
looked like a whole trail of them that
should look like that machinist whoa
they're like sus looking but I feel like
they'd be tasty if they were steamed
is that starfish no it's not starfish
what the [__] is it I want to kick it
dude you want to kick it are they I
think it could kick me dude if I saw
that on the beach I'm running up and
[__] kicking that [__] dude so here's
a hint it's not um it's not alive what
but it was
it was alive here's a closer photo
they look scary isn't that crazy that
[__] really looks like that this looks
like I could eat it it was alive like
look at all those meaty legs I know it's
kind of thick what is that bro
they captured it very I know so they do
you you know War of the Worlds the movie
yeah with Tom Cruise uh-huh yeah that's
what people really thought it was the
war of the world's aliens but I've never
seen those songs
[Laughter]
I use the tube in the middle like it's
not like in the like it's like this yeah
so it turns out like this photographer
took a picture of that and he posted it
he didn't know people were gonna freak
out but then all these people had
theories of what it was and they all got
scared to go to the beach yeah yeah that
doesn't look like super warm and
inviting all it is it's just dead aloe
vera plants oh it looks upside down also
someone had to place them then no they
they were under the water and they
washed up and then that's how they come
out aloe vera grows in water it comes
out like that that's not what happens
then it's upside down and then seeing
that and being like whoa you're gonna go
up and kick it bro it was just gonna
flop over yeah all right that's some
crazy [__] that for real does look like
War of the World [__] like aliens that
[__] just come through and like that
looks like an invasion is starting if
there was an apocalypse do you think you
could make it
I don't know it depends what kind song
like there's a bunch of these oh [__]
like hundreds of a thousand percent
because my initial reaction is to kick
it yeah wait to kick it or kick it to
kick the [__] out of it right they can't
get her to kick that like 93 too or like
yeah you know some people have fight or
flight I have kick okay and there's no
ore kick or did nope I just look at I'm
like what the [__] is that yeah but what
happens when you run out you kick it and
as you kick it it just eats your whole
[__] foot oh my that's the risk I
take my friend do you have a strong like
roundhouse kick he does do karate let me
see let me see Lucy I'm tired you see
that boot right there in the [__] I
kicked it already that was you no that's
gonna be filled with water but I have to
now ready I'm lazy I don't know I do it
late I do it like this wait wait hold on
this is how you would kick the the war
why do I feel like a lot of stupid is
about to happen
it hits her in the face oh my God yo
that would have been hilarious boom
right there into it she's got a black
eye or she caught it every time you want
to hit on the girl be like watch this
dude that'd be kind of if it flew across
[Laughter]
but it was my mouth
I want to be like Nacho Libre and hire
some guys so when I'm on a date they're
like punking us and I just kick them yo
you want to do that but it's the wrong
gang of guys just like nachos [__] me up
do you think you could win a street
fight I think I would lose really hard
it depends if it's like a crazy person
my body is fake so I think like once
they like knock off like I would be like
yo I'm done I don't have insurance
you're like that's it yeah that's all
yeah but it might make you more like
mobile it might be like cyborg like I'm
built you know like I don't feel it
that's true whatever or Mr Fantastic you
might be able to like stretch yeah yeah
I didn't sit for a whole year after my
BBL I remembered that yeah I was built
like a hamster before so I was like
really scared that one day I would I
would wake up and be built like hang
kill again it was my nightmare I was
like I'm like you yeah I was like I
can't have that haven't so I like would
have a cushion that like made me like
float and I would sit on my knees
everywhere I roller coasters airplanes
cars you went on roller coasters dude I
didn't give a [__] and I didn't sit for
one year and then I be I sat on accident
and I realized my ass is going nowhere I
was like
it's still here
oh wow what did you where did you get a
bbo like last year so how long did they
last they're sorry pretty much for Life
bro for Life yeah well what happens is
there's an implant in the butt no it's
uh Brazil you're fat that gets moved
lipo from my tummy and like my arms I
also bought ABS I bought abs for 2K how
do you buy how do you buy apps
how do you buy an ass how do you do that
how did you do that wait I want to buy
that yeah how do they do that they they
tell me that if you don't work out and
you like kind of like lose your [__]
then that you'll still have abs but
it'll look really weird so now I have to
work out because if not I will look
really silly but how did you buy the
hair you could buy these ads for two
thousand but you got to work out every
day
so I well I got
um lipo 360 and my BBL and arm lipo and
abatch all on the same day so I got my
it felt like a sexy car accident
I was like ouch but I'm gonna be sexier
and then I was in recovery home for
three weeks it was intense oh my like
bandages everywhere yeah like I was like
in my father and bleeding and stuff and
then I but yo I got abs for 2K
but what is
what does it take away the fat and then
like no I don't did you guys see my ass
yeah I did yeah no did they throw in
like a six-pack or something you can ask
for like an Olympic etch or you could
just get like I just wanted like a
feminine line like I wanted like this
looks like wow so is there something in
there or is it just like they took out
they I don't I don't know what is it how
they like take I think it's the way they
take the life yeah because all of us
have abs underneath yes so then they're
chiseling the fat away yeah I think so
and then now I work out a lot I work out
two hours every day I worked out before
I came here you that's why that's why
you should go to barbell Brigade yeah
I bought these abs these were built in
the gym too maintaining delicious so if
you buy your body you have to work out
if you don't you have the option people
think if oh you get your BBL you're good
for life no bro because we see stupid
ass bbls every day like you have to like
look if you want to look proportionate
yeah you are gonna have to work out or
if you want it to look real too yeah so
with my BBL
was it was just weird and asinine so
getting my BBL where now my ass my fat
cells are in my ass and there's like
less fat here like my weight
distribution is better so now I have a
new Foundation of my body so now I can
build off of this foundation so it's
like a new framework yeah yeah because
ultimately I could have worked out with
my old body but I never would have had
hips or ass like this so you worked out
after you got your surgery yeah yeah
because like I I was like weird it was
just like in my mind I was like why
would I work out I'm never gonna get
like this body I wanted I did I wanted
to look feminine and curvy which I could
have worked out I would have been lean
and like athletic but I wanted to look
like a woman which is what I wanted now
I understand how this one big booty girl
I follow has abs yeah I didn't know that
that was because you would have to have
I should pay two G's you have to
actually have a low body fat I'm like
and how are you gonna have thick butt
and thighs right but with like you can
see the ABS I'm like how is that
possible but now it's like now I can
have ass and now I can actually just do
abs every day and now it's like like but
this wouldn't exist in the Medieval ages
you know like if you plop me into
Medieval ages they would be like what
the [__] dude
we must worship her no let's burn her at
the stage she's a witch how is this
possible I'm gonna be a couple hours
with her
did you have any like post uh trauma or
like is it mess with your mental like I
made it like I was really picky about my
doctor
um and my doctor was actually a Doctor
Young in Houston he's an Asian doctor
hey H-Town it sound and it's like he
wasn't I wanted like a natural like a
natural BBL I didn't want to look like I
wanted to look engorged I wanted you I
wanted to type a BBL where like if I
walked in the airport you'd be like damn
yeah but I didn't want it to be like
damn like how do you wipe you want to
make people miss their flights
for flights
cuts the news
some BBL doctors especially in La like
Beverly Hills BBL doctors they'll like
look too natural and it's like bro I
wanna I still want to look oh it's too
nice something happened yeah like I
looked like I got like ass now you know
this did not exist 20 years ago right if
you're gonna do it science has gone
forth and created a new species of BBL
Asians yeah we did wow
I was very picky about making sure I
chose the right doctor like great
reputation yeah also I didn't want to go
out of state just because I don't speak
the language if I went to like Mexico or
some [__] yeah you say Houston
no I was just I was sorry I'm talking I
was talking about bart has a bigger butt
than he had four years ago he got cakes
he says a body of a gorilla we're all
jealous share your cake share your cake
like he takes don't be insecure and
spreads his butt cheeks no not that far
but it's kind of nice oh I could tell oh
Nacho Libre
that should inhaled the [__]
underwear dude my body moved you
couldn't tell
the surgery that could like make your
dick three inches bigger but it would
take three inches from your height would
you do it oh I don't care about a big
dick I want I don't got enough height to
be I don't got height to be given
can I just do one inch no she talked
about it I want more senses you want
more like oh you want more nerve endings
I want way more yeah because I want it
to be like from the stand like you know
how just the head is kind of really
sensitive you want a more sensitive I
want it to be like they [__] lick the
stem and I come oh that's what I want I
feel like you wouldn't want that because
wouldn't you want like a journey it's
not about the destination it's about to
Journey but then like yeah it's
beautiful I just I just want to come
fast like really fast would you would
you uh make your dick more sensitive to
be less sensitive as a person
wow
wow I don't give a [__]
where people come up to they go yeah
he has a button in his balls bro and he
presses the button and then his dick is
hard Oh no you're lying oh yeah yeah
it's like it's bigger or or softer it's
just like that way it works no matter
what wait did he do that because he had
an issue or did he do that I think he
just did it because he did porn for so
many years like it's just it must be
desensitized and it's like you don't
want to shoot it up because I feel like
that would shorten your lifetime in porn
and plus like taking Cialis every day
probably isn't good for you but if you
implant like a button then like this
fool can have sex and then he could bust
a nut and then he can go flash it and he
can go Boop he must be a shower then he
already being like this guy's meat is
hella soft and Squishy I
started
another is like I feel like smaller
dicks get like rock hard because like
all the blood flow crawlers yeah whereas
like guys have arm dicks like it's just
kind of like squishier yeah it's like
solid but it's like sea cucumber yeah
it's like you they can like kind of like
jam it in there slowly but they won't
like have the difference sucks for them
[__]
[Music]